about 100 very talented artists from
Southern Nevada and surrounding states
are going to be gathering in Summerlin
for the Annual Festival of Arts the
sponsors of this segment here to tell us
more about that is Jenny pivoto thanks
for joining us today Jenny thanks for
having me this is something people look
forward to because really these are the
best of the best that are selected to
participate in this event yes yes this
event is a juried event so all of the
artists that are entered into the show
have gone through a selection process
and they're all there by choice it's
it's about 100 artists all selling Fine
Art on Milan at downtown Summerlin yeah
and it's just it's amazing to see that
collection and that many great artists
gathered so this is something people in
this time of year with the weather being
what it is people look forward to it yes
it's one of my favorite fall events too
and this is our 26th Year we're really
excited to have everybody back out we
have some really new additions this year
too in addition to our seasoned fine
artists that'll be selling art on the
lawn we also have some up and coming
artists from Bishop Gorman Alexander
Dawson and the Meadow School who will be
doing live art demonstrations throughout
the show we have really fantastic art
and science activities for kids the Las
Vegas Review Journal has a really cool
character art for kids to do salt do
prints with Discovery Children's Museum
and we even have UNLV engineering school
and The National Society of land
surveyors out there with science
activities for kids to complete so
obviously a great family event yes great
for families it's a good presentation
about all art and culture in fact one of
our new elements this year is the
Southern Nevada Paiute District which
will be throughout the dining Arroyo and
we'll have Southern Nevada pyots with
new art and friends who will have Fine
Art and folk art for sale and we we have
three different dance circles that will
be doing Native American dance
presentations throughout the day that
sounds fantastic let's get to the nuts
and bolts of it where when how can
people get there and how well it's this
weekend Saturday and Sunday from 10 a.m
to 5 p.m we'll be there it's free and
open to public uh entire family is
welcome including your furry friends as
long as they're on a leash makes sense
and of course you have an opportunity to
purchase some of the art and this is a a
sample of what people will see right
this is just a sample with different
mediums of the art that you'll see you
can see we have photography we have
jewelry the Nevada clay Guild with
porcelain and other types of pottery and
oil painting a little bit of something
for everybody it's all about finding
what you love it will be there I promise
I so love it and these artists I
mentioned in the beginning that most of
them are from Southern Nevada or is it
surrounding states what is the makeup of
that it's actually a healthy mix we do
have some local artists we also have
Regional and a few National artists all
right so it's it's all over uh it should
be a lot of fun and it has been for some
25 plus years now so Jenny thanks so
much for being with us here today thank
you so much just want to remind people
Summerlin Festival of Arts going on
October 8th and 9th on the lawn at
downtown Summerlin you can get a lot
more information by going to
summerlin.com